you're like an astronaut in the sense
that like I'm not joking around how many
people have done Weekend Update the
history of the show 12 13 like it's a
small amount of people you really are in
a very rare group of people yeah I think
so I think so and I I actually am an
astronaut by the way it's funny you
should say that I want to tell you a
story sometime about Buzz Aldrin but I
know at this at the time
I I met at Buzz Aldrin
the show you know he called me Wise Guy
he was gonna kick my ass he reminded me
of like a Midwest college football coach
like No Nonsense yeah yeah yeah I asked
him you were ever afraid of uh getting
not getting off the moon he goes what
are you a wise guy I just met him I said
what's this guy talking about no I'm
serious he goes why wouldn't why
wouldn't we get off the moon I said
because he's a rocket scientist
everything's on paper it's supposed to
work I said I don't know I get my car
sometimes it doesn't start so why
wouldn't and he thought about he goes
well you know we get into the Luna
module on the way back and there's a
little few sticking out but we just
called Houston they said push it back in
that's all oh that's funny but I thought
I thought I was gonna be in a fight with
buzz on the beach you know